hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast revealing the hidden landscape
of structural variants in cancer genomes
presented by dr. Jonas cor lock chief
scientific officer Pacific Biosciences I
am Xavier chairs of lab routes and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of the your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appears on the screen our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Carlock I will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you very much and hello everyone
and thank you to the organizers great
pleasure to be back at the lab booths
and today's presentation as Europe is
about cancer and I'd like to highlight
how quick bio sequencing uniquely can
identify structure variants and other
features of cancer biology and cancer
genomes that are otherwise hidden with
previous technology so the topics for
today I'd like to start with a brief
technology update and then focus most of
the time on applications and
opportunities that are provided by
lollipop our sequencing in three areas
structure of genetic variation in the
area of targeted sequencing and in the
area of full-length RNA seek or I should
seek as we call it and then I'll close
by giving an update and an outlook on
our technology roadmap so with regard to
sequencing and sequencing performance
there are three main categories that you
want to look at and really whenever you
evaluate any sequencing technology those
are the three areas that matter with
regard to performance and fundamentally
what we've tried to do is that by our
sequencing is to give the best possible
performance in all three criteria and
categories simultaneously so
coincidentally yesterday we released
officially the latest sequencing
chemistry and so I'm happy to report
that we further increase the throughput
and the yield and these categories so
I'm going to go through them briefly so
with regard to the read length the
length of the sequence reads as you know
PacBio provides very long reads that are
now up to 30 kilobases on average for
genomic DNA and up to 100 kilobases on
average for amplicons
on the right I have shown just two
representative examples on the topics
genomic DNA human DNA and you can see
that the average is well over 30
kilobases in fact a metric which is
called the read and 50 that's the read
length which harbors more than half of
the data so more than half of the reads
are in more than half of the bases are
in reads greater than 48 kilobases and
then for amplicons it's even
longer so the Reid and fifty there half
of the data is and reads that span more
than 135 kilobases with regard to high
consensus accuracy that's always been
high because the errors are random as
you know Don the raw read level the
errors are higher in fact by sequencing
but because the errors are random you
reach consensus very quickly in fact
with this new chemistry the raw read
error is reduced so that you reach
consensus more quickly now at twenty
fold coverage you reach QB 40 or 99.99%
and at around 40 fold coverage to reach
QB 54 99.999% or less than one arrow in
a hundred thousand sequence basis and
then similarly has always been the case
there's very minimal bias with regard to
sequence complexity or what's shown here
on the right the GC content so
regardless of whether your DNA sequences
80 rich or GCC rich you get the same
kind of read lengths and base quality
and that really simplifies the by
automatic analysis because it's much
more uniform compared to other data sets
like Illumina data and so this has been
proven and demonstrated in the community
by many papers and commentaries
highlighting the advantages of smart
sequencing comparing bias with regard to
those different technologies and then a
more recent paper looking for the
applications and utilities towards the
clinical sequencing and medical
diagnostics the authors concluded that
smart sequencing offers advantages over
short rate sequencers and I will
highlight some of those in particular
with regard to oncology and Cancer
Research and so fundamentally what we
were trying to do then as I mentioned
this to build a system that has very
good performance in all three of those
criteria and not compromised like other
technologies - for example of course the
short rate sequencers they don't have
long reads and they also quite a
pronounced bias and then other long
reads or link tree sequencing
technologies may have long reads but
they suffer from systematic errors
systematic bias and also
regard to coverage by now initially of
course this kind of performance came at
a price and that was the reduce
throughput but we have worked very hard
on increasing the throughput now by over
two thousand fold compared to the
initial launch back about six years ago
first on the rs2 and now on the sequel
system so that now on genomic DNA you
had up to 20 Giga bases per smart cell
run and up to 50 Giga bases per smart
cell run for amplicons and currently
it's possible to run 12 cells in a
walkaway operation on the sequel machine
so with push of a button you can
generate up to 600 Giga bases or 0.6
tera bases per machine run and so that
now it's all based on the same
foundation of high quality that I
mentioned earlier and so now we're
reaching a fairly serious two-port that
makes a number of projects that
previously would have been perhaps too
slow or too cost-prohibitive makes them
affordable and doable in a timely manner
and so because of these improvements
we've seen a steady increase in the
adoption and in the publication out for
tiers the historical evolution of the
peer review publications that feature
PacBio sequencing in all fields of
science not just cancer so they're well
over 4,300 publications about five new
papers are published every day on
average that highlight the utilities and
the advantages of smart sequencing over
other techniques and so with this
introduction I'd like to highlight for
the rest of the talk the opportunities
that exist in cancer research
specifically to the three topics I
mentioned so I'd like to start with
structural genetic variation structural
variants are larger differences from the
reference genome so you know about snips
and that's a one base pair change and
structure variants by contrast have been
defined as differences to the reference
genome that have 50 base pairs and
larger and there are many different
types so you can have sequence deleted
or novel sequences so
there are 10 in duplications intersperse
duplications inversions translocations
and all of these different kinds of
variation have been termed under the
umbrella term structure variation and it
has also been recognized that the short
rate sequencer like Illumina are not
very well suited to sequence and resolve
this type of genetic variation here just
two examples where in a review article
by Rick Wilson Evan Eichler and Mark
Jason it was noted that short reads
parallel sequencing is insufficient to
generate high-quality genome assemblies
or to resolve most structure variation
and so far that in a commentary by the
editors of Nature Genetics they started
the article by saying that it's time to
stop thinking that just doing more DNA
sequencing meaning more shortly
sequencing will give us the variants
that determine human traits and so the
abilities by PacBio sequencing to reveal
this hidden variation was highlighted
over the past few years starting with a
nature paper on title resolving the
complexity of the human genome really
for the first time using single molecule
sequencing highlighting that it's not
possible to resolve this type of genetic
variation and then followed by quite a
number of examples I've just listed two
here of ethnically specific the Nobel
Assemblies of human genomes is for the
Chinese reference genome is the Korean
reference genome there have been others
in the past in fact we know now over 40
publicly available assemblies using
PacBio sequencing data and on our
website and you see the link on the
bottom I encourage you to check this out
it's an interactive map where you can
click on the different types of genome
assemblies and get more information get
the accession numbers to the database
and so forth and so fact 5 has clearly
been a leader in redefining the
reference genomes and the ethnicities
they're all now why is that important in
cancer and just to give one example of
why that is it's a very nice review
article that appears in plus one a few
years ago
highlighting that there is a strong
relationship between the ethnic
background of the patient and their
evaluation of the cancer risk so it was
highlighted in this article that most
cancer markers do not validate in an
ethnic group other than the one that
constituted the discovery cohorts and
the authors look in very detail in six
cancer studies addressing the
association between cancer risk and
allelic variations and they found that a
significant result in one ethnic group
was usually not reproducible in other
ethnicities and wealth card studies so
it very much matters looking at the
particular ethnicity and looking at all
the genetic variation looking at snips
and this type of structure variation now
do we have a complete picture of all the
variants that drive cancer in these
different ethnicities and the answer is
clearly no through these studies of high
profile phone coverage looking at these
ethnic genomes much of the structure
variation was discovered to know them
and discovered for the first time there
about 20,000 events roughly balanced
about 10,000 deletions over 50 bases and
10,000 insertions that exist between
human genomes that makes them different
from each other and respect iOS has been
shown that you can capture all of these
whereas of Illumina you see on the
bottom left you only capture about 4,000
you've missed about 16,000 and on the
bottom right is shown a just a simple
schematic highlighting that actually in
terms of number of bases the majority of
the bases that make us different from
each other are in these types of
structure area there are about 20,000
events but because they're large or they
Harbor many many bases and so these
PacBio genome projects reveal that we
had significantly underestimated the
abundance of these types of variants
even in normal and healthy genomes and
certainly in cancer genomes as well it's
also been known from for example the
cancer genome
other large-scale resources studies that
structure variants are common in most
cancers so here's just one example of
analyzing pan-cancer patterns for
somatic copy number alterations and they
studied thousands of samples found that
whole genome duplication events were
very common but also that there were
recurrent focal hotspots for copy number
variants that were identified in each
chromosome and that indicates that just
like single base variation some
structure grains are likely driver
mutations aren't a very strong selective
pressure highlighting the need to
sequence these and to resolve them and
to understand them if you want to
understand cancer biology and cancer
progression and so quite recently a few
months ago there was I think a landmark
paper by Mike Schatz is depicted here on
the upper right on for the first time
comprehensively characterizing a cancer
genome with regard to all types of
genetic variation and so he utilized the
very well studied breast cancer cell
line as kabr 3 and in this genome
research paper looked at this particular
genome whip-smart sequencing revealed
nearly 20,000 variants found most of
which were actually missed by the short
route sequencing comparison in addition
he does fulling transcriptome sequencing
that revealed several novelty fusions
within and be very complex genetic
variants and so in comparison of short
and long we technologies for cancer
genome analysis this paper revealed that
there's a significant gap in our
knowledge about the complexity of cancer
genomes so I encourage you to check out
this paper and pull just a couple
examples of long-range structure
variants were found thousands of
insertions deletions duplications and
inversions and translocations and then
on the right you see the comparison on
the left column with the long read
variant size distribution and on the
right is a short read comparison and so
you can see there's hardly any red and a
very very few blue as well with the
short reads technology so the short
reads missed nearly all of the
insertions and the vast majority of the
deletions that were called are smart
sequencing so I think this figure on the
right highlights very powerfully and
visually how much is missed when you
just do illumination route sequencing
and here's just one other example of
understanding and highlighting and
resolving these very complex two
infusions so I just think I'm going to
talk a little bit later identified 53
putative gene fusions many of them were
previously unknown and then Mike and
Maria nada Scott wrote the software
split thread are that can be used to
systematically search for these potato
confusions and so you can see that these
can be sometimes very complex this
particular fusion has components from
three chromosomes 8 14 and 17 and
because of the long reads and the
contiguity that you get with PEG bio
sequencing data you can resolve this
unequivocally which is not possible for
Shore tree techniques so the key
takeaways from this really landmark
paper that I think justifiably got
featured on the cover of the genome
research issue I think two months ago
where that long read sequencing resolved
far more bases in the genome that are
affected by structural variants compared
to just a single nucleotide
polymorphisms they show that long way
sequencing can expose complex variants
with great certainty in context
suggesting that there are these very
complex to fusions inverted duplications
and complex event may be found in other
cancer genomes and because these other
types of complex variants are likely
present in other cancer genomes that
were not found in this particular breast
cancer cell line the authors believe
that it is essential to continue
building a catalogue of these variant
types using the best available
technologies in order to enhance our
understanding of cancer
just a couple just one I think one more
example on a renal cell carcinoma a
paper that came out a little while back
looking at structure variations the
authors looked at 66 tumor samples and
did an exhaustive genomic analysis to
uncover possible driver mutations and
they found that 10% of these types of
tumors had an overexpression in this
particular gene that was driven by
structure variance and the breakpoints
all these rearrangements were precisely
mapped with the PacBio Longridge
amplicon sequencing so mic shots paper
was a whole genome approach and this one
was a targeted approach to look at these
kinds of structural rearrangements and
so here's another example on the lower
right from the University of California
San Diego highlighting that these types
of genetic rearrangements can number one
be driving mutations and number two
they're often not captured with
next-generation sequencing but are
visible with long read sequencing the
second topic that I'd like to talk about
is targeted sequencing and specifically
how the long reads can facilitate
phasing of mutations over the two
different alleles and so this has been
of course recognized as a very important
aspect of now we're talking about most
of single nucleotide polymorphisms so
single base changes and they are it
matters critically to understand whether
if you have to repay shion's have showed
in this very simple schematic whether
these two mutations indicated by the
eggs are present on the two different
alleles so of course you have two copies
in every cell from the mother and one
from the father
to have two copies of every gene and for
example in cancer for tumor suppressor
genes it matters whether those two
mutations are on the two different
alleles which means in the top that both
alleles are defective both genes are now
defective or whether those two same
mutations are co-occurring in our phase
with regard to one another on the same
allele and in this particular case you
will
one ileana you know w defective but the
other allele critically is still intact
and so this has important ramifications
for understanding cancer progression and
also understanding patient treatment so
the ability of the long reads to
immediately provide these kinds of
linkage relationships have been
recognized early on this is an older
paper phasing these types of snips with
smart sequencing and the paper concluded
that smart sequencing can immediately
provide the linkage relationships
between the snips in the target segment
and that makes it of course inherently
computationally much more simple because
you get the information out within an
individual long read rather than with
Illumina where you have to try to piece
that together for the short reads so the
paper highlighted in gene called 88
looking at exon 5 comes directly
comparing the smart technology of
Illumina finding great components but
then you can see on the on the right
that with Illumina for two of these very
well known mutations in test you can see
it says no reads no reads so this also
highlights the bias that you sometimes
have an Illumina just not giving you any
information and so the lack of bias with
pecan sequencing can get you the phone
coverage and the publication load of
these particular both cell lines and
primary tumors and then finally the
linkage the long reads provide you the
linkage information so they allow you to
understand that in many cases there's
much higher at rigidity
so not just to haplotypes and to alleles
but in some cases three or four and then
gives you an immediate idea about how
these particular types of configurations
can have occurred as is shown in the
middle schematic another example about
characterizing the criminality of these
complex tumors as the mutations
accumulate in a tumor it's important to
understand whether multiple mutations
occur on this front and come from the
same tumor cell or whether they're from
different tumor cells that would be
called
poly clonality and this is a relatively
new paper looking at leukemia
types of cancer and showing powerfully
that with the Sanger and the shorter II
technologies in the middle panel here
not all the mutations were identified
and also they were not phased so compare
this is on a patient in panel a on the
top you see in a patient that was
monitored and sampled over a particular
time period in 2008 in August and then
again in July of 2013 and then the same
sample was subjected to saying or in
short read sequencing two mutations were
found in August with these technologies
and then six mutations in July and then
compare that to the long read smart
sequencing results where you can
actually find many more mutations for
both time points and also ambiguous
unambiguously say that none of these
were phased none of these came from the
same tumor cell and all of these came
from different tumor cells so really
quite pronounced poly clonality
which was otherwise hidden from these
NGS data and so this was some of
amplicons the same is true of course
with capture prophase capture and you
know we don't have a preference of what
you want to shrew select or nimble Gen Y
DT or the different kind of technologies
that are out there but you can visually
very clearly see that there's a big
difference between looking at five
kilobytes of 5000 base drivers effect by
on the top panel the two panels
immediately phasing the mutation and you
can see that in this particular example
all five heterozygous snips are based on
one allele and the other
completely according with the reference
genome that information is lost with the
aluminum 200 base pair of short reads
because the contiguity in the context
connectivity is not long enough to
provide you that information here's
another example another cancer another
gene that's important in cancer and
again you can see the resolving power
and with Illumina again because of bias
you don't even get full coverage of this
region so you're actually missing some
of these variants all together then with
regard to some cancer genes on the
analysis is further complicated in the
sense that there are students on present
so this was nicely reviewed by review
paper by Berkut film Coutu years ago
looking at highly homologous genes in a
molecular diagnostic setting of course
it is now recognized that they are well
over 10,000 unique so genes that are
associated to genes and these are
challenging for short reads
next-generation sequencing and also
Sanger sequencing because the sequences
are so similar so in this paper you have
as you can see on the top highlighted in
pink the so-called NGS deadzone so those
are all genes listed here that we know
cause the diseases that have listed on
the right but they can currently be
accessed and so our analysis indicates
that there is about 200 of those and
over 80% of those are now resolvable
with the pec biotechnology and I just
want to highlight one gene that's
important in cancer and let PMS to PMS
to is causing mutations in PMO's to
cause nurture syndrome which is an
aggressive form of hereditary colon
cancer the pms to gene is very large
it's about 30 KB and that's shown here
on the top in this blue designation and
the analogy is complicated by the fact
that there is a pseudo gene nearby that
extends over about half of the size of
the gene and has a very high homology
over 99% sequence identity which makes
the analysis very challenging we have
undertaken this analysis looking at
full-length amplicons of this particular
portion and as you can see on the top
you can design primers so that only the
gene will amplify because the forward
primer is outside of the region that our
sub pseudo gene and so on the bottom or
two samples that are highlighted and the
result that you get are two sequences
each of them are 16 kilobytes in length
for each sample and those were present a
fully phased folding consensus sequence
with all the variations revolved for the
mother and the father allele the next
example in targeted sequencing that I
would like to highlight is a fairly
recent paper that is also relevant to
leukemia and specifically t-cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemia and the authors
use smart sequencing to reveal and then
show the biological significance of
having these dual mutations and allowing
a visibility of whether their phase on
one allele whether they occur on
different alleles so this jak free
tyrosine kinase is mutated in ten to
sixteen percent of all these cases and
then these mutations in jak 3 allow for
constituent activation of these fat
downstream genes even in the absence of
these activating cytokines that are
normally required for T cell maturation
and proliferation during development so
as these mutations can then lead to
proliferation and cell growth and
eventually can lead to the cancer and so
for some of the samples the authors
applied acquired sequencing to determine
whether multiple mutations were on the
same allele around two different alleles
and they found that about one third of
those mutants cases either had almost I
guess or a dual jak 3 mutations and then
they were able to precisely and
quantitatively break out whether on
individual reads both mutations were
identified or whether they were on dis
coming from
cancer cells and so the complete the
first conclusion was that there was a
stepwise accumulation of these mutations
first this one and then the additional
ones where they acquired later but if in
this figure is shown that it's precisely
important to understand and have the
knowledge of whether you have these
double mutants because the independent
growth in these mouse and model cells is
highly dependent on whether these
mutations happen on the same allele or
whether they happen on individual
alleles you can see there's quite a
dramatic difference in the cell growth
and so the conclusion is that phasing of
these cancer mutations here again is a
real key to understanding their
biological significance and phasing
potentially additive mutants in these
distinct protein domains also requires
uniquely this one route sequencing so I
hope these these types of examples give
you an idea of how long read sequencing
can be quite powerful use and so before
I move over to the next subject I just
wanted to mention that with regard to
the procedure we've now made it a quite
straightforward
we have barcodes that allow you to pool
many samples for this type of targeted
sequencing whether it's amplicons or
whether it's prophase enrichment you can
add the barcodes and then pool hundreds
of targets and hundreds of samples in a
single to sequence tag at one smart cell
and then the software will automatically
be multiplex the different barcodes and
analyze for each barcode and give you
the final results and so that makes it
cost-effective and allows the processing
and sequencing of many samples and then
the other consideration that I'd like to
just conclude with is that in contrast
to short read or Sanger sequencing when
your target region becomes that say
greater than one kilobase and it becomes
very cumbersome where you then now have
to walk yourself
estable PCRs at multiple primers or have
short reads that you need to assemble
none of that complexity is necessary
require sequencing because we have long
reads up to 10 KB and I given you as
I've shown you an example 16 kilobases
we would confidently say that whatever
ends upon you can make no matter how
long it is no matter what sequence it is
you can sequence that in one piece and
give you the full information so that
makes it a lot easier both from the
library prep and the initial PCR context
as well as from the by automatic
analysis so then I'd like to close with
one last example I've highlighted
examples on how there are many
opportunities for long retardant
sequencing with Peck pile that go beyond
the you know 250 bases that are
schematically shown on the left that you
can get the phenomena on the right to
discriminate in some pseudogenes get
full length phase gene sequencing
looking extreme sequence context and the
last example that I want to show in the
area of cancer relevance is for minor
variant detection of phases where you
detect these minor variants of two more
related mutations in a background of a
large excess of normal cells lots of
cells and then also phase those
mutations and understanding whether they
come from the same cancer cell norm so
for this we have a unique way of doing
the sequencing all the previous examples
that I talked about were based on
standard sequencing I was just shown on
the left and as you may know acquires a
unique way of sequencing which we call
circular consensus sequencing where
you'll like these hairpin adapter to
each end of the double-stranded DNA
molecule and then the polymerase will go
around the structure of multiple types
and sequence the same DNA molecule
multiple times that gets you information
about the forward strength and the
first rent of that same molecule and
that allows you to get very highly
accurate consensus sequences on an
individual DNA molecule and of course
that is important in these mixed samples
that occur often in in cancer samples
and actually the the jak3 example is
already one the second one is in the
area of chronic myeloid leukemia and a
paper here by researchers in Sweden
highlighted the unique capability of
single molecule only sequencing in this
case of cDNA of the Povey variable gene
to identify mutations at a very low
level allow for the earlier detection of
these mutations that may confer
resistance to the particular drug
treatment so the author show that in
some cases it would have been possible
to detect a particular resistance
mutations four months earlier compared
to what they were doing before and then
significantly because now it's possible
to sequence the entire VCR able gene
they pick up mutations that were missed
by other methods all the ones with an
asterisk as you see on the bottom legend
were missed by other methods and
identify these compound mutations so are
they're doubling resistant mutants
and of course that is very relevant
because similarly to the picture before
if you have two mutations two resistance
mutations but they have come from
different tumor cells the combination
drug therapy on the top still work
because drug a kills tumor cell one and
drug because tumor cell two however if
both of these mutations are inside the
same tumor cell that tumor cell will now
be multi drug resistant and the
combination drug therapy will fail so
the authors in Sweden have that now as
part of their clinical routine
laboratory tests and care of patients in
a superior method of screening these
patients and informing about their drug
therapy they're in Sweden
so as the third on topic then and I for
rating transition because the last
example what in the area of full-length
RNA seek or ICC because we call it it's
been well understood now that the full
complexity of the transcriptome so all
the different gene products and
messenger RNA isoforms cannot be fully
resolved and characterized with the
shorter e technologies and papayas ICC
cries inform sequencing solution
provides a much superior workflow there
because of the long reads you get
full-length cDNA reads and each read
coming off the machine is automatically
a polling isoform and so there's no
assembly required and it's full
certainty about these particular select
isoforms long reads are one thing but
then their lack of bias once again
matters as well this is from an earlier
paper in detail comparing the different
technologies so you see on the top here
that was still four by four than the
different flavors of Illumina PacBio
and then I'm torn and in the y-axis you
see it's the mRNA from the five prime to
the three prime in these heat maps and
you can just visually already see that
back bar because has a much more even
representation especially on the ends of
the transcripts with regard to the
sequencing depth and getting high
quality sequence so there are many
publications on this method on this
istick method well over 100 and on the
bottom here is the link to our
publications with reference database if
you're interested and I just want to
give a couple of examples how this has
been utilized in the area of oncology
cancer I'm going to start with what is
probably one of the now classical and
one of the first ICC papers this was
back published already five years ago in
2013 looking at what was probably the
best studied human transcriptome that's
embryonic stem cells and even though
literally billions of Illumina reads
have been spend on the sample the
authors found many new genes 273 jeans
many Liza forms and concluded that the
process even the process of identifying
all the genes in the human genome is
likely far from complete and I'm showing
this example because I wanted to
highlight that in some cases it can take
some time to then understand the
importance of these novelties so in the
second paper a few of those 273 new
genes were studied in more detail by
this group and they found that it's
precisely those new genes that have a
big role in regularity regulating Tory
potency during human pre-implantation
development or nuclear reprogramming so
those are key processes that also help
to understand cancer biology at the
fundamental molecular level and so it's
a it was a very nice example that these
new discoveries are not just jeans or
John's that nobody cares about it was
precisely the genes that people needed
to know about to understand these
important processes if you're interested
there was a very nice technology feature
in nature highlighting the story a
little bit more on how it went from
understanding and discovering these new
genes
- then elucidating their function with
regard to long non-coding RNAs this is
uniquely not possible in a high
throughput manner with long resequencing
this paper by the genic code consortium
in Nature Genetics very nicely
highlights this this paper will known
approximately doubles the number of
targeted loci the number of long
non-coding rnas in the Google genome
outperforming existing Shore tree
techniques they definitively
characterized the genomic features of
these types of RNAs and because it's now
done in an automated and high-throughput
fashion it removes a long-standing
bottleneck for transcriptome annotation
generating these high-quality
full-length transcript models at high
throughput scales how can that be used
towards clinical research the first
example is in the area of colorectal
cancer of course the earlier you
identify the colorectal cancer the
better it is treatable and the current
tests are there's colonoscopy but the
current tests that are non-invasive
don't have very good sensitivity and
they have specifically very bad
specificity and sorry very bad
sensitivity of only about 27% when you
deal with the precancerous or the Avenue
ones and that means that the detection
is often later than optimal and the
survival rates and the treatment is much
much worse so new biomarkers are needed
to improve the early detection and it's
been known that gene splicing mrna
splicing plays a major role in tumor
progression and then that the proteins
that arise from these myths light mRNAs
may make very good biomarkers for
identifying these precursor lesions as
well as the tumors for earlier detection
and so in this paper by a researcher
from the Netherlands they showed that by
applying ISO C they were able to
identify over 1,400 additional potential
isoforms specific peptides so a large
reservoir that was previously unknown
for identifying these powerful
biomarkers the second example I would
like to highlight where ICC can have
great utility and in addition it's a
really nice example showing that if you
make errors if you make mistakes upfront
it can really harm the downstream
analysis and the translational science
so this paper is in the area of prostate
cancer and of course for prostate cancer
androgen
deprivation therapy is the current
standard of care and it's complicated by
the fact that you have these androgen
receptor variants AR b7 or every nine
that can occur which cause resistance
and make the patient's make that energy
and deprivation therapy it affected for
the patient so androgen receptor here's
the showing the full gene and so if you
have the full-length a hydrogen receptor
gene on the top right here it's a dex
ons and all in blue and these variants
of energon receptor can occur shown here
in red by these cryptic exons cryptic
and there's cryptic exon 3 and cryptic
exon 5 and so forth and specifically
this Energon variant energy sector
variants 7 which is shown in the middle
right here which has this cryptic exon 3
has been intensely studied and has been
shown to be a potential biomarker for
this type of resistance occurrence has
been the subject of inhibitory RNA
studies to try to knockdown the
expression of these particular variants
and so forth and these studies had all
relied on the fact that it was thought
that this red cryptic exon 3 was
specific to ARB 7 and so unfortunately
though this was not the case and so this
was this is what this paper is showing
that using Isis di cystic method from
PacBio revealed that the previously
reported structure of one other of these
androgen receptor variants was incorrect
in fact as a rv9 that was initially
previously thought to only have this
cryptic exon v was actually had two
thousand four hundred bases more
sequence and significantly harvard both
cryptic exon v and cryptic exon 3 and
you can see now that that's a big
problem because all the studies that has
assumed that cryptic exon 3 is specific
to a rv7 now have to be essentially
filled in the garbage and reinterpreted
and worst case have to be redone because
C 3 also occurs
every nine and so these studies that
thought to specifically target one
variant where in fact targeting two
variants and so the effect on gene
expression is now ambiguous and can't be
interpreted so forth so I think it's a
really powerful example that shows that
if you want to if you have incorrect or
incomplete information upfront there are
now literally dozens of studies that
have to be redone and reinterpreted
another example for in the area of
cancer now looking at a gene fusion is
work that was done by Australian
researchers again in prostate cancer
this is the fusion between human
relaxing one and relaxing two and the
authors describe that they had really
thrown the kitchen sink of all different
technologies at this but were unable to
resolve the structure and the isoforms
of this particular fusion gene they then
applied smart sequencing and were able
to resolve the complete structure and
highlight isoforms and again this paper
really nicely highlights that it's
really important to understand whether
you're dealing with the wild-type gene
or with the fusion gene and so just
focusing your attention on the two in
the middle and the rightmost graphs it
shows that in the middle you have the
response of the fusion gene and on the
right you have the response of the
relaxing one wild-type gene and you can
see that they're basically opposite so
the two different isoforms show
opposites responses in expression in
these in this particular cell model when
you deprive them of androgen or when you
add energy to the growth media so if you
don't know what you're looking at you
might misinterpret or not at all
understand how these cells respond and
why so then with regard to the new
chemistry and the new performance of the
sequence system you can expect about a
half a million reads of consensus reads
and that gives rise through the
bioinformatics to about a quarter
million of folding isoform reads and
where this was applied as the last
example looking at the
nal m6 a well-studied cell line and this
is just an example of looking at milk
isoforms in black on the top are the
isoforms of Peck bio in blue on the
bottom are the refseq annotations and so
you can see that there are isoforms that
the ISIS EQ method reveals here
highlighted by the arrow that are not
found in refseq as well as you can see
retained intron events that can often
arise in cancer which are not captured
and typically not resolvable with the
shorter technologies and so on the RNA
sequencing of the b and t the PSL
revealed a subset of 7% of the cases for
example here in this study are
characterized by a ducts for
deregulation so you can have this over
expression of the ducts for numbers that
linked to this receptor in activation
the Cascade of these transcriptional
changes and so this particular cell line
that was sequence was I think that I was
talking about is representative of this
class of these b-cell q2 acute leukemia
cancers and in a collaboration of
researchers from some Jude Children's
Hospital they found that both short read
RNA seek as well as connects genomics
were unable to reveal the complete
sequence of this particular fusion
driver mutation that's because this
particular ducts for domain region
contains these repeat regions which are
interspersed and dispersed throughout
the genome and so you need long reads
long contiguous reads to map these
particular regions and both short
resequencing and 10 extra comics
sequencing failed whereas the dapeng
biotechnology was possible just as once
mark cell to get continuous sequence
information through this particular
entire locus completely resolving IgH
region with ducks foraging
so in conclusion the ICG method has been
now optimized for the sequel system
there's no more site selection needed
much simplified for library preparation
and also analysis workflow which lowers
the initial cost for generating these
types of whole transcriptome data in
many cases only one smart sequel cell is
required to unambiguously identify these
types of structure brands now it's such
an expression level and there's no
additional follow-up that the
researchers are doing
we forgot to t-cell and b-cell receptor
repertoire sequencing researchers from
Europe again from the Netherlands of
this very nice paper applying of
optimizing the PCR and then applying
smart sequencing for full-length
immunoglobulin sequencing to identify
these rearrangements so they identified
the full-length functional BBJ sequences
in cell lines in primary cells or in
external biopsies and found that through
the full-length long repair our
sequencing you can cover the entire vdj
sequences in a single read and thereby
get an unbiased comprehensive analysis
of the b-cell receptor repertoire in
both healthy reactors and neoplastic
conditions and this was since followed
up by a number of studies looking at the
B cell receptor repertoire in this way
for different kinds of cancers these
types of lymphoma and following up with
other biological studies so as I
mentioned the library preparation has
become much simpler
no more site selection is required if
you are interested in enriching
specifically for the longer transcripts
for the genes there is an optional site
selection but this has become much
easier compared to Beckham Tamar's two
days and there's a lot more information
that's available on our website with
regard to targeted sequencing with
regard to be pulling for the genome or
transcriptome sequencing and so I'd like
to encourage you to look at that
student Li there are many applications
of Isis ich I talked about
whole transcriptome sequencing and
targeted sequencing we realize of course
that very hard single-cell sequencing
and so single-cell ICC to look at the
transcript structure not just accounting
and single cells has been demonstrated
the first paper was by Ian Macaulay who
sent at the Sanger Institute a few years
back where actually last year no this
was furious Becker's I apologize looking
at some cancer cells and in the middle
panel to be you see that the PacBio
technology was able to reveal and
resolve multiple isoforms of these teen
fusions where at the top and the bottom
and red and blue those are the Illumina
short reads that happen to span the
fusion junctions and while you can get
that kind of information the identity of
different isoforms was hidden and since
then they have been a number of other
papers that have come out on the isoform
diversity in the mouse brain and then in
the bar by archives a very new paper by
Hagen Silva and colleagues looking at
single-cell ice inform RNA sequencing
across thousands of cells this was done
not for cancer this was done in the
brain but I think the method is
certainly very applicable to single-cell
Studies on the transcriptome
architecture in cancer cells so then
finally I just want to show one slide
and say a few words about our technology
roadmap I talked about that we steadily
increase the throughput based on the
high quality foundation and make the
workflow easier for the users and so
we're certainly not done
I mentioned that just yesterday we
announced the latest chemistry to
increase import and accuracy and
application updates so that's shown you
in the middle and then an early 2019
will have an improved and simplified
library preparation kit that will come
out and then in 2019 and Beyond will
have a new chip that will have an
Eightfold increase in the number of
sequencing sites so that will increase
the overall throughput person
one by another factor of eight so the
combination of this latest chemistry
update with the 8m smart cell will
result in an additional order of
magnitude throughput increase over the
next 12 months and so all the things
that I've talked about of course it then
scales into among four larger project in
making the existing product project
faster and more affordable because you
have this massively high throughput so
with that I'd like to finish I thank you
for your attention at the time and of
course I'd be happy to answer any
questions
Thank You dr. Carlock for that
informative presentation we will now set
the Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email now let's get
started a first question is what is the
limit on amplicons with regard to SMRT
sequencing yeah certainly um so I think
I mentioned that you know there's really
we don't really see a limit so no matter
you know whatever you can make with the
PCR long-range PCR regardless of how
long it is and regardless of what kind
of sequence
it has sequence complexity and as we
feel quite confident that you can
sequence it with PacBio sequencing and
I've shown some examples with well over
10,000 bases on the short side if if you
want to use it for let's say for very a
validation for example that's fine too
so the small the shortest PCR amplify
that I seen being sequence for that
purpose are you know 100 200 bases and
you get obviously get perfect reads
every time the CCS mechanism that I
talked about I should mention that we
also see opportunities for you know
workflow efficiencies and price
efficiencies to you can really view the
smart cell as a universal sequencing
unit or holder in that you don't have to
sequence the same gene or the same
target separated for different smart
says you can mix different targets
together and there's much less of a size
bias now so if you have you know like I
mentioned PCR able amplicons and then
you have other types of amplicons you
can pool and mix them together because
the sequencing is single molecule
sequencing each DNA molecule is going to
sequence individually separately and
they're going to be separated by the
barcode and by the sequence by the
software so if you have only a few
samples of this type and a few samples
of that type you can mix those together
and then you don't have to wait as long
some customers feel like they they need
to wait for the samples to arrive and
sort of fill up one work of smart cell
and in many cases we found it's very
successful that just as you view a
Sanger plate where you can have many
different types of targets and genes on
a Sanger play that sequence those in one
run you can do that with smart
sequencing as well there are no physical
boundaries like you would have on a
96-well plate anymore but that
separation is afforded at the molecular
basis by virtue of the sequencing so in
that case in essence we feel that the
system is really quite flexible and can
be adjusted to quite a large breadth of
sequencing centers that have very
different types of sample throughput
enemy
and
do you have tools to do the structural
variation calling with PacBio
yeah absolutely so we have now a fully
functional and mature workflow in our
analysis package which is called
SmartLink and the analysis package
SmartLink version 6 which actually also
came out yesterday concurrently with the
new sequencing chemistry has improved
workflow for structural variant analysis
that faster it also allows for join
calling if you have let's say a child
and the two parents or if you have
population cohorts and significantly
I've only talked about structure
variants and defined them as genetic
variation that's larger than 50 base
pairs but with this new structure
variant caller we actually go down to 20
base pairs on all the way to many many
thousands and we also call inversions
and translocations so a spectrum of
genetic variation that even exceeds
structure variation so that's all
available either in the web interface or
for advanced bioinformatics experts in a
command-line interface that has more
flexibility regard to parameter
adjustment and so forth so yeah that's
the functionality that we realize is
very important and we have fully
incorporated that now in our software
and for last question if ethnicity plays
such an important role in cancer risk
how are we going to get to precision
medicine for all patients yeah that's a
good question and you know the more you
know the more you realize how much you
don't know yet right so as I showed we
have just begun to reveal the hidden
landscape of structure variation not
only in cancer but even in the normal
healthy population so I think what has
to happen is that we have to sequence a
lot more human genomes with this type of
sequencing approach to get a complete
picture of the genetic variation then we
have to sequence you know all types of
cancers to understand for the first time
comprehensively what is changing in
those cancers get a get a real view of
these types of complex rearrangements
that were so powerfully highlighted by
the paper by mic shots that I mentioned
for the first time and it really gives a
new view on what is happening in these
cancers so far we've only had a partial
view and in some cases the important
events I'm sure will have been hidden
from us and we have to do that for the
different ethnicities so we need to
understand whether lung cancer in an
Asian population is different with
regard to the common drivers from lung
cancer and other ethnicities and so
forth so a lot more sequencing has to
happen a lot more data analysis the
creation of dedicated databases of
structural variants common structure
variants versus cancer-causing variants
and so it's really a recapitulation of
what's been happening in the single
nucleotide polymorphism in the snip
based approaches where you have snip DB
and clinvar and these types of
equivalents now have to be generated but
I think I think there's no doubt that
that will happen
over the next few years and I think
there's great potential that this will
really significantly enhance the
therapies and help the lives of you know
thousands and tens of thousands of
patients and so we certainly look
forward to collaborating and working
with the scientific community and the
cancer community to taking that path
well we'd like to once again thank dr.
Carlock for his presentation I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from
labradorite um you know when this
webcast will be available for replay pre
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye